oh get off of me
did you have any idea when you were
making the movie that 25 years later it
would still be such a cult favorite i
don't think i was thinking about
anything in the future when i was 18
years old
cher which is my character is the most
perfectly dressed see i'm outing bye
e.t was on the set of the 90s cult
classic about a bunch of spoiled beverly
hills high schoolers with fancy clothes
cars and cell phones as i grew up i did
not like
these kind of girls this is the patent
leather look
now this is very in i got my box just
hanging out because you know it's the
new fashion i remember
telling my friends that i was doing a
movie and stacy dash was playing my
girlfriend in it
woman why don't you be answering any of
my pages oh my god the kissing scene i
remember i rushed the kiss
and like get this reese witherspoon and
tiffany thiessen were originally
considered for the role of cher
no way but it was an 18 year old alicia
who caught the eye
of the director i was on my treadmill
watching mtv
and there was this video about this girl
when i met her she was just so adorable
she had a drink and she had the like
straw
she was like like like a kid
do you prefer fashion victims or
assembly challenge
fashionista's share had 63 outfit
changes
alicia got to keep them all but like a
ding-dong i got home with all the
clothes and i was like how am i going to
wear these mary janes now out and so i
just gave a lot of it away
and um so i don't have any of it oops my
bad
this is the hot seat
okay this girl right here did you enjoy
that oh my gosh i enjoyed it
more than you know i had the best time
in the world my buns they don't feel
nothing like steel
clueless also launched the career of the
late brittany murphy
it was a breakout role for the star who
passed away in 2009.
i love when brittany murphy says you're
a virgin
can't drive your virgin
who can't drive this is paul rudd and he
plays
the college boy josh it was the second
movie that i ever did
it was the first one that ever came out
but it was the second movie that i ever
did
oh wow you're filling out there oh wow
your face is catching up with your mouth
were you at all nervous for that kiss
with paul rudd don't remember
oh it's such a nice kiss i'm sure if i
could remember
i'm sure i loved it and paul's delicious
so how could you not